Sí así es se trató de un viaje breve
pero intenso ayer entre fontes ruta y
Georgia meloni En qué founderlayer
anunció un acuerdo de 100 millones de
euros para que el país para que túnez
pueda abordar esta migración irregular
hay que tener en cuenta que la gran
mayoría de migrantes salen de este país
también de Libia sobre todo hacia las
costas italianas más de 50 personas han
llegado a las costas italianas
provenientes de este país pero también a
cambio de reformas la Unión Europea
también ha prometido un enorme paquete
de inversiones como comentadas de más de
mil millones de euros para la
transformación económica del país se
trata de un salvavidas para un país que
ahora mismo se encuentra en la banca
rota y por lo tanto es de Gran
importancia porque sobre todo a cambio
va a poder también parar estos flujos
migratorios de migrantes aún así este
viaje no ha estado exento de polémica
hay que tener en cuenta que el
presidente del país seáis cait es una es
un personaje muy polémico de hecho ahora
mismo tiene plenos poderes tiene una
deriva autoritaria que preocupa
especialmente a la Unión Europea y
también por todo ello no ha habido ha
habido mucha polémica aún así Georgia
meloni con este viaje se encuentra muy
reforzada por su mano dura contra la
migración